un an jour pour jour la réussite
envahissait l'Ukraine depuis ce conflit
à bouleversé l'ordre du Monde
diplomatique militaire économique le
continent africain se relevant à peine
du covid-19 a aussi eu à gérer les
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
pour comprendre on ouvre cette édition
en allant retrouver en direct notre
correspondant à Dakar Sarah Sakho Sarah
Macky Sall le président sénégalais qui
vient tout juste de céder sa place à la
tête de l'Union africaine a eu à gérer
cette crise et cette guerre et on peut
dire qu'il a multiplié les actions
diplomatiques au tout début de la crise
voilà alors Mike ficelle prend son
mandat la tête de l'Union africaine en
février dernier donc quand cette guerre
éclate et tout de suite il demande une
désescalade des violences nous voulons
ainsi c'est le feu c'est ça la position
de l'Afrique a-t-il martelé à plusieurs
reprises par la suite alors sa position
elle est claire l'Afrique est une
victime collatérale de cette guerre le
continent on le sait est très dépendant
aux exportations de céréales et
d'engrais également donc qui arrive de
Russie et d'Ukraine les économies
africaines ont été mises à mal par les
difficultés d'approvisionnement en
énergie la hausse du dollar sur les
marchés les prix ont flambé et donc
c'était évidemment extrêmement compliqué
pour les économies africaines à l'époque
Macky Sall il avait répété plusieurs
fois craignait donc une famille une
pénurie alimentaire sur le continent
donc il met donc sa diplomatie africaine
au service de la médiation il affiche
rapidement une politique de non alignée
de neutralité l'idée c'est simplement
d'obtenir donc dans l'absolu la paix
mais plus concrètement la reprise des
exportations de céréales alors le temps
fort de cette médiation de ces
tentatives de médiation c'est sans doute
sa rencontre avec Vladimir Poutine le
président russe c'était en juin dernier
et il a rappelé à Vladimir Poutine
d'ailleurs l'effort diplomatique selon
lui des pays africains malgré d'énormes
pressions lui a-t-il dit sous entendu
pression des pays occidentaux la
majorité des pays africains n'ont pas
condamné la Russie alors toujours dans
cet esprit de neutralité il a également
multiplier les contacts avec la partie
ukrainienne enfin pour terminer je
dirais que avec sa casquette de
président du Sénégal il a également
adopté cette politique de non-alignement
son pays le Sénégal est frappé de plein
fouet par la crise comme tous les pays
du continent d'ailleurs 10% d'inflation
l'an dernier selon un chiffre officiel
et l'État pas dû lourdement mettre la
main à la poche pour essayer d'amortir
les chocs avec des subventions le
directeur du commerce intérieur nous
parlait d'un montant global de près de
700 millions d'euros c'est énorme et ça
pèse évidemment sur les finances
publiques du pays